[Music]  it's time for et social study what the  stars are posting online to ask people  what's inspiring them what's inspiring  you that you've been writing about life  changes so drastically all the time and  you know I guess when I got married I  was I started writing a bunch of love  songs and now here we are four years  later and I'm still writing love songs  about my happy we are so I'm not to find  some different content to write about  well country singer Thomas read  definitely has something new to write  about he and his wife Lauren are  expecting the couple announced Wednesday  that Lauren is pregnant and they are in  the process of adopting each child from  Africa blac chyna posts a sassy new  photo from her latest shoot and the  Pippin family is posting from vacation  last week a source told et at Larsa and  Scottie Pippen are now working on their  marriage  after it was announced they were  divorcing  you